I'd like to thank everybody for
attending this this talk I'd like to
thank the organizers at by our
conference live for inviting me to make
the presentation I'm going to talk to
you today about the post translational
control of the molecular chaperone hsp90
but before I get to that particular
topic I want to put hsp90 in context on
explain why it's an important novel
molecular target in cancer so as you can
see from this title slide I hsp90 as a
molecular chaperone has roles to play in
the function of normal cells but it's
hijacked by cancer cells hsp90 is
ubiquitously expressed in all kingdoms
except for archaea and eukaryotes there
are a number of orthologs of hsp90 in
yeast which is a very useful model to
study hsp90 structure and function there
are our two jeans and a stress inducing
HSP 82 and a constitutively expressed
HSC 82 these genes are highly homologous
although not completely identical
deletion of both is lethal so yeast
cells need at least one hsp90 gene to be
expressed for viability in humans
there's a similar situation there's a
beta isoform that is constitutively
expressed its knockout actually is
embryologically lethal and there's an
alpha isoform that is stress induced
mice can survive knockout of hsp90 alpha
but males are sterile humans also
express to other hsp90 related genes one
called grp 94 is a molecular chaperone
that's restricted to the endoplasmic
reticulum and another called trap one is
restricted to the mitochondria so the
obvious question why target a
housekeeping protein like hsp90 in
cancer as I said in normal cells hsp90
is part of the pro stasis network that
helps to maintain homeostasis cancer
cells have utilized the protea stasis
network of proteins including hsp90 to
maintain the function and stability of
mutated and over expressed genes many of
which are oncogenes another way of
looking at this is that a normal
function of hsp90 both at the cell
tissue and organismal level is to sense
environmental stress and to coordinate a
cells and tissues and organisms
responses to such environmental stress
to promote survival so it's not a big
leap to consider the fact that cancer
cells generally exist at all times and
the presence of one type of
environmental stress learn or another as
diagrammed here hsp90 is part of a
circuit that reads nutrient stress
stress from the proteome due to this
folding hypoxic stress and the genetic
instability and aneuploidy for which
can't
cancer cells are well known and turns on
and regulates numerous pathways in the
cell that helps the cell in this case
the cancer cell cope with these
different kinds of stresses on the far
right of the slide are just a listing of
the few of the client proteins that
depend on hsp90 for their function and
stability and these proteins help to
modulate the pathways that cancer cells
use to protect themselves from
environmental and chemical stress this
model is based on a crystal structure of
bacterial hsp90 bacterial hsp90 and
mammalian hsp90 are actually not that
very different the domain structure is
maintained as you can see there's an
endo domain to which ATP binds a middle
domain which is a site or co chaperone
and substrate binding and a c-terminal
domain which serves as a dimerization
site this is a model of one pro tumor of
hsp90 but hsp90 exists as a dimer that
is dimerized through motifs in the
c-terminal domain of each pro t'mer ATP
binding and ATP hydrolysis are essential
to the function of hsp90 in in vivo this
is a simple model showing that in the
presence of ATP which binds to the end
domains of the pro tumors the Protagoras
can come together to dimerize in a
transient fashion and and this allows
hsp90 to hydrolyze the ATP
and this binding hydrolysis and
conformational dynamics are all
essential to the ability of hsp90 to
chaperone its clients now the story is
more complicated than that hsp90 does
not work on its own it's a TPS activity
in the absence of accessory proteins is
extremely low and a number of accessory
proteins term co chaperones and shown
here help to control the rate of ATP
binding and hydrolysis the two co
chaperones shown in red slow down the
chaperone cycle and the conformational
dynamics of pine ATP binding and this is
important for loading client proteins on
to hsp90 whereas AHA one shown in green
helps to enhance the ATP hydrolyzing
activity of hsp90 and I'll talk more on
this later so this is a close-up of the
end domain of one pro t'mer of hsp90 on
the left showing where ATP binds in a
unique pocket in the end of domains of
each of the pro tumors on the right are
two of the original hsp90 inhibitors
that were identified in the early in
middle 1990s geldanamycin and we're
Disick all and the point of this slide
is to show that these inhibitors bind to
the ATP pocket and replace ATP in that
pocket what this slide shows is a
clinical development of hsp90 inhibitors
over time
so Delta no meissen was identified in
1970 we identified hsp90 as its
molecular target in 1994 the first hsp90
inhibitor to enter the clinic a
derivative of guilty atomizing called 17
AG began clinical trial in 1999 and
since then 18 chemically distinct hsp90
inhibitors have entered the clinic until
2006 these hsp90 inhibitors were all
versions of guilt Anna meissen but in
2006 the first totally synthetic hsp90
inhibitor was identified and tested and
since then a number of synthetic hsp90
inhibitors have reached various stages
of clinical evaluation to date one hsp90
inhibitor sta 9090 also known as Gannett
SP is in phase 3 clinical trial so to go
back to the model of hsp90 chaperone
cycle which involves a number of
conformational changes together with ATP
binding and hydrolysis the role of drugs
in blocking the hsp90 cycle occurs
because these drugs displays ATP does
preventing the conformational changes
that ensue upon ATP binding in which are
essential for hsp90 to chaperone its
clients so in the presence of these
drugs such as geldanamycin with Disick
all and all of the synthetic inhibitors
that had been developed since they
blocked the chaperone cycle and client
proteins are
delivered to e3 ubiquitin ligases that
caused a ubiquitination and then
subsequent degradation by the produce oh
so client proteins of hsp90 in the
presence of hsp90 inhibitors are
ubiquitous and and generally degraded in
the produce aisle to III s have been
identified that promote this process one
called chip another called column 5
there are likely more e3's as well this
is an example of what happens to a
typical hsp90 client protein the kinase
to be rap in the presence of an hsp90
inhibitor in this case 17kg this is a
Western blot showing that over time the
level of the client declines to levels
that are almost undetectable within 16
to 24 hours of drug treatment in some
cases depending on the sensitivity of
the client this decay and protein
expression and stability can be even
faster it's important to note that this
is not an effect on mrna it's not in
effect on transcription it's an effect
on protein stability and this loss of
b-raf protein is secondary to its
ubiquitination and degradation in the
produce on not all proteins of course
our clients of hsp90 and sometimes
proteins that are very closely related
may diverge in their dependence on hsp90
and we show that here with the kinases
or b2 and herb d1 or b1 also known as
EGF receptor much less sensitive to
hsp90 inhibition whereas herb b2 is
exquisitely
institute showing here within four to
six hours there be two protein is lost
from tumor cells whereas it takes much
longer 16 to 24 hours to have an effect
on your FB one expression again even
though the loss of her d2 is so quick it
really depends on its ubiquitination as
shown in this slide from a paper
published in 1996 within 15 minutes of
drug treatment the levels of her key to
protein shown on the left begin to
decline but this is accompanied by
dramatically enhanced ubiquitination if
one were to include a proteasome
inhibitor in this experiment you would
see that you would protect the client
protein from degradation although in
many cases the client will become
insoluble and precipitate out of the
soluble fraction of the zone another
client that is very dependent on hsp90
and those very sensitive to hsp90 in
condition is the kinase EML for elk
which is characteristic of certain forms
of lung cancer as you can see in the
western blot on the lower left email for
out both of us correlated in this active
form as well as the total out is even
worth sensitive in this experiment than
then her two or herb me too and in an
animal experiment one can see regression
of tumors that are driven by EML for
alch when animals are treated with an
hsp90
hibbett ur so one way to think about
hsp90 inhibition as an alternative
strategy to inhibit a number of cases in
the cell with a single stroke as opposed
to using tkis which have specificity for
a particular type of kinase or family
hsp90 inhibition is able to target a
number of kinases that are hsp90
dependent at the same time so to turn to
to some clinical evaluations of hsp90
inhibitors in cancer patients a study
published a few years ago was the first
to demonstrate the efficacy of an hsp90
inhibitor and this was in her2-positive
burpee to positive breast cancer
patients that had been treated and
responded to Herceptin but eventually
progressed on Herceptin alone the
researchers showed that when hsp90
inhibitor in this case 17 AEG was added
on to Herceptin partial responses were
restored and these are all patients that
were progressing on Herceptin alone the
response rate was twenty six percent and
the overall rate of benefit was
sixty-three percent this has now been
validated for other hsp90 inhibitors
phase two analysis of non-small cell
lung cancer i has shown that the hsp90
inhibitor can attest bid as monotherapy
has a significant activity and out
positive one cancer so these are lung
cancers that are driven by the activated
form of out that I was discussing in the
previous couple of slides and and here
75% of the patients examined in this
trial that were out positive responded
to gannett tested as a mono therapy this
is an example of a patient's tumor this
patient was on croissant nib the Alcan
hibbett ER for one year before
progressing when this patient was then
administered three doses of gannett test
fit the hsp90 inhibitor you can see that
there was additional shrinkage of the
tumor that was no longer responsive to
the alkene hitter so it's clear that
tumors that are driven by highly
sensitive hsp90 clients such as her too
or early to and alch are most likely to
be responsive to hsp90 inhibitor therapy
in vivo this is an example of a non
small cell lung cancer patient whose
tumor is B wrap dependent as you
remember the rap is also an hsp90 client
this patient had been on a number of
therapies the average duration of each
was from two to four months after
lacking responses over the course of 13
months to the various drugs shown in the
slide after four cycles of can attest if
it's mono therapy there was clear
evidence of tumor shrinkage
this is a patient with triple negative
breast cancer so not dependent on her to
actually it's not clear what drives this
particular form of breast cancer and yet
it also responds to a single agent hsp90
inhibitor after not responding to a
series of therapies so hsp90 inhibition
is likely to have a broad applicability
and a number of different types of
tumors that are driven by different
molecular targets is there evidence that
the amount of hsp90 that a tumor
expresses is predictive of patient
survival and the answer to that is yes
the initial study showing this was
published a few years ago looking at a
series of non-small-cell lung cancers
prospectively non-small cell lung cancer
is genetically very unstable and so
there are many gains and losses in gene
expression so the green here are games
in gene expression multicopy genes the
red are deletions of various genes and
portions of chromosomes so if you look
closely you can see that the hsp90 alpha
locus is among the regions that are not
uncommon ly deleted in non-small cell
lung cancer so what this study did was
to look at a series of 32 patients with
non-small cell lung cancer and to look
at their overall survival by
and correlate that to the level of hsp90
expression or to the deletion of the
portion of the chromosome that encode
the hsp90 alpha gene so in panel a if
you look at hsp90 expression ah high or
normal you can see that normal
expression of hsp90 compared to low
expression of hsp90 had markedly
different overall so survival well
expression of hsp90 predicted for better
overall survival and this is validated
in two additional sets of tumors solo in
non-small cell lung cancer low
expression of hsp90 predicts for better
overall survival more recently this was
also shown to be the case in breast
cancer in another paper where the
investigators did a similar analysis in
this case looking at recurrence-free
survival of triple negative breast
cancer and finding that those patients
whose cancers had upregulated hsp90
expression had a shorter recurrence-free
survival time than did everybody else so
again the expression level of hsp90 is a
negative prognostic marker both for
overall survival and for recurrence-free
survival suggesting that targeting hsp90
is going to inhibit something that
drives cancers and there is clinical
evidence now that this is the case for
triple negative breast cancer or
non-small cell lung cancer and for her2
positive breast cancer
so for the second half of the talk now I
want to focus on the regulation of hsp90
in normal cells but also in cancer cells
and this regulation is by post
translational modifications to hsp90 and
and by this term I mean phosphorylation
acetylation ubiquitination etc all of
the modification shown on this slide
have been identified by hungee and many
of them have been shown to affect not
only drug sensitivity but also hsp90
activity itself its location inside the
cell and I'm going to show you some
examples of each of these focusing on
phosphorylation as the
post-translational change because
phosphorylation has been the most
actively investigated of the
modifications to hsp90 so this is the
slide showing hsp90 alpha and beta the
stress inducible form and the
constitutive form listing some but not
all of the phosphorylation sites that
have been identified as you can see many
of the sites occur in both hsp90 alpha
and beta since the proteins are highly
homologous but there are two sites in
particular outlined in green that occur
only in hsp90 alpha and not in beta
these are three names five and seven and
hsp90 album and so I'm going to give you
three examples of how plus four elation
or the lack thereof of either threonine
5 and 7
why 38 in hsp90 alpha and y 3 13 in
hsp90 alpha effect drug sensitivity
hsp90 activity and location inside the
cell 43 needs t54 uh 43 needs five and
seven we know the kinase that
phosphorylates these residues it's
dna-pk which is itself a client of hsp90
for why 38 we know the kinase is we won
also a client of hsp90 and for why 313
we know that yes a closely related
protein to see sorry is able to
phosphorylate this residue although we
also know that it is not the only enzyme
that is able to do so yes it's also a
client of hsp90 as is son so a theme
that's appearing here is that many of
the kinase is that our clients of hsp90
seem also to be able to phosphorylate
the protein with different impacts on
its location and its function as well as
its drug sensitivity so first let's look
at this residue in the end domain which
is why 24 and yeast and 38 in mammalian
hsp90 alpha that is phosphorylated by me
run pharmacologic inhibition or
silencing Obree one sensitizes both East
and cancer cells to hsp90 inhibition and
what we're showing here is we're looking
at the percent of apoptosis and
escalating doses of the hsp90 inhibitor
17
gee you can see that on its own at these
concentrations 17 AG does not induce a
high degree of paper ptosis but if we
include a we won inhibitor at a dose
that by itself is minimally a photonic
the combination of hsp90 inhibitor and
we want inhibitor it induces synergistic
a pitocin this is true in two different
tumor lines pc3 which is derived from a
prostate cancer and hela cells which is
the ride from cervical cancer so
combination of we won inhibitor and
hsp90 inhibitor is synergistically a
patata this is also true for the newer
synthetic hsp90 inhibitors we're showing
in pc-3 cells here the two of these
drugs sta 90 90 Organa test boob and snx
2112 also demonstrate synergistic 8 the
ptosis when combined with low-dose we
want inhibitor that in itself is not a
pataga these results can be translated
to ant to animal studies looking at the
growth of tumors here we're using a
model of peace III in xenograft form
we're using doses of 17 ag and we won
inhibitor that are low enough so that on
their own as single agents do not cause
significant inhibition and tumor growth
but when combined at these doses which
you can see in the orange line showed
significant growth inhibition again
demonstrating synergy between very low
dose we won inhibitor and hsp90
and since we want inhibitors currently
undergoing early clinical evaluation it
should be possible sometime soon to
perform a clinical study in cancer
patients combining we want inhibitor and
hsp90 inhibitor the second example I
want to talk to you about is how
phosphorylation can affect hsp90
activity so as I mentioned hsp90 has
very low ATP a's activity inherently and
in order for it to be functional in
cells it's a TPS activity has to be
increased this is performed by a co
chaperone an accessory protein called
AHA one which stimulates the inherently
low 80 pas activity of hsp90 as shown on
this slide up to 10 role but in cells
there is much more hsp90 than AHA one so
mechanisms must exist for hsp90
populations in cells to recruit a AHA
one in order to stimulate atps activity
this is just showing an cartoon which I
showed you a number of slides ago
showing that the chaperone cycle is
dependent on AHA one to promote ATP
hydrolysis so here is the proximal
location of why 313 it's in the M domain
of hsp90 what we initially found was
that if we made a possible mimic
mutation of the tyrosine which is why
313 he's shown on the
right here and immunoprecipitated either
transfected wild-type hsp90 flag hsp90
or transfected flag hsp90 why 313 e and
you can see where immunoprecipitate
equivalent amounts of hsp90 endogenous
aha one associate much more profoundly
and abundantly with hsp90 why 313 e
compared to wild-type hsp90 these
experiments were done in 293 cells if we
look at the purified proteins aha one
and hsp90 and measure affinity of aha
one for wild-type hsp90 compared to
hsp90 why 313 e you can see that even
with purified protein measurements
there's nearly a four-fold increase in
the affinity of AHA one for the possible
mimic hsp90 why 313 e compared to
wild-type hsp90 consistent with the
pull-down data obtained in 293 cells we
then went on to make an antibody
specifically recognizing phospho why 313
hsp90 and used it in an experiment where
we immunoprecipitated total hsp90 with
an antibody to hsp90 called AC 88
compared to an immuno precipitation of
aha one and for this purpose we
transfected 293 cells with flag aha one
we then Western blot it for hsp90 in the
upper panels and then Western blotted
for phospho why 313 hsp90 in the lower
panels
and what you can see is that the hsp90
that is co precipitating with flag ah-ha
one is much more likely to be
phosphorylated on Y 313 then is the
general population of hsp90 this is
graphically shown underneath the western
blot where we've made a ratio of hsp90
plus boat y 3 13 / total hsp90 and from
this graph you can see that the hsp90
associating with aha one is Sevenfold
more buzz for elated on y 313 than is
the general population of hsp90 all
these data taken together suggests that
phosphorylation of Y 313 may serve as a
recruitment signal in the context of the
cell for a pool of hsp90 need to recruit
AHA 1 and therefore this might be
predicted to be an actively chaperoning
population of hsp90 to confirm that AHA
one is better able to increase the ATP
a's activity of why applause for y 313
hsp90 we go back to purified protein
data here showing that ancient that AHA
one is more potently able to stimulate
the ATP a's activity of equal amounts of
Y 313 e hsp90 compared to wild-type
hsp90 demonstrating again that phospho y
313 hsp90 is likely to be much more
readily activated in terms of its eight
EPA's activity as a consequence of
recruiting AHA one to the complex of
chaperones so I mentioned a minute ago
that this may also identify actively
chaperoning pools of hsp90 and we did an
immunocytochemical see distinct
populations of hsp90 in the cell using
the antibody to phospho y 313 this is
sustained looking at total hsp90 using
an antibody that generally recognizes
hsp90 in the cell the the green signal
is hsp90 the blue signal is a nuclear
stain so what this shows is what is
readily accepted that nearly all of
hsp90 roughly ninety five to ninety
seven percent in cytoplasmic there is a
small amount in the nucleus but the vast
majority of hsp90 cytoplasmic but it's
relatively uniformly distributed in the
cytosol in contrast if we look to the
pattern of staining we see with the
antibody two possible why 313 hsp90 you
see that in these two bladder cancer
lines the pattern is distinctly
different from total hsp90 nrt for cell
shown on the left there's a punctate
pattern of distribution and TCC cells
shown on the right the pattern is even
more distinct where it appears that
phospho y 313 hsp90 is localized to the
periphery of the cytoplasm perhaps on
the inner portion of the membranes of
these zones so the question remains are
these sites of actively chaperoning
hsp90
and this is an area of intense
investigation at present but it is clear
from these experiments that unique
phosphorylation of hsp90 is able to
identify unique pools of the chaperone
in the cell another example of this is
going to be shown here looking at
phosphorylation of three needs five and
seven in this case only in hsp90 alpha
since these residues are not three
innings in the beta isoform of hsp90
before getting to that i want to
introduce the extrinsic a pathetic sick
signal pathway that sells used this
refers to death receptors that exists on
the plasma membranes of cells that are
activated by ligands binding to them
which in turn activates a cash-based
cascade leading to nuclear AP ptosis as
evidenced by DNA fragmentation trail a
peptide is one of the ligands of these
death receptors as shown in this cartoon
so trail binding to an activation of
these death receptor pathways leads
eventually to nuclear fragmentation and
nuclear ap ptosis this pathway is
distinct from the pathway of the
intrinsic AP ptosis which I'm not going
to discuss here very shortly after trail
binding two cells within minutes to a
few hours gamma h2ax which is a plus for
a phosphorylated form of histone 2ax
appears in cells that are destined to
undergo
nuclear fragmentation and is shown by
the red stain in in this picture these
experiments are done in hct116 which is
the colon cancer line so in this
particular picture although there are a
number of cells as evidenced by Dappy
stain which is a nuclear stain in the
field two of the cells are currently
positive for gamma h2ax and so are
beginning to undergo nuclear
fragmentation on the right in the green
color you see that the same cells that
are positive for gamma h2ax are also
positive 4 plus 4 related 3 means 57
hsp90 Albert and if you overlay the
picture we can confirm that the same
cells positive 4 plus 4 elated h2ax are
also positive 4 plus 4 elated t57 HSP 90
if you remember I mentioned a minute ago
that 95 to ninety-seven percent of hsp90
is site of solid perhaps three to five
percent its nuclear this phosphorylation
of three needs five and seven identifies
a nuclear population of hsp90 that's
phosphorylated in response to this
extrinsic AP ptosis inducing agent one
can see that this is dna-pk dependent so
in panel a we use inhibitors of ATM
kinase that's also involved in trail
activated AP ptosis and an inhibitor
dna-pk and only the inhibitor dna-pk is
able to inhibit
phosphorylation of three names five and
seven and hsp90 alpha in response to
trail in panel B we're looking at cells
where dna-pk is knocked out compared to
parental cells and in the cells where
dna-pk is knocked out there is
absolutely no phosphorylation of three
innings five and seven and hsp90 alpha
in response to trail importantly there
is also no cause for relation of gamma
h2ax in these cells demonstrating that
in hct116 cells trail-induced
phosphorylation of both h2ax and
threonine 57 hsp90 alpha is dna-pk
dependent here to make things a little
more complicated we're showing the
dna-pk activation by trail actually
requires hsp90 alpha if you remember I
mentioned a short while ago the DNA PK
is a client of hsp90 and so hsp90 is
required to maintain the kinase in a
metastable state that is able to respond
to trail-induced activation and here
we're showing in fact that in cells
where hsp90 alpha is knocked down with
si are RNA in panel a there is minimal
appearance of phospho t57 hsp90 in
response to trail there's minimal
appearance of gamma h2ax in response to
trail and this is in the presence of the
beta isoform of hsp90 so this phenomenon
of t57 phosphorylation and
gamma h2ax phosphorylation by dna-pk is
hsp90 alpha dependent this is a unique
role for hsp90 alpha in the nucleus
themselves in panel seed we're just
quantifying the reduced amount of gamma
h2ax and t57 plus for relation when
hsp90 alpha is knocked down and in
panels DN e we're looking at measures of
eight the ptosis and in the gray bars
which reflect AP ptosis in cells knocked
down for hsp90 alpha you can see reduced
ap ptosis reduce nuclear egg mitosis
compared to the black bars where
wild-type hsp90 alpha is normally
expressed so in some these data
demonstrate that hsp90 is regulated both
functionally in terms of drug
sensitivity and in terms of location in
the cell by post translational changes
we've given you several examples here
where phosphorylation of different
residues in hsp90 can have these
different effects and in some cases
where antibodies exist to the
phosphorylated residues it's been
possible to document in addition to
making phospho than medic or non prosper
relatable hsp90 mutants that these
modifications actually occur in cells
either under steady state conditions or
when cells are challenged by
environmental stress so taken together I
want to leave you with the understanding
that
hsp90 an important part of the prettiest
asus network of normal cells is hijacked
by cancer cells to promote survival in
the face of genetic instability chemical
stress and environmental stress and that
there one has to keep in mind that
there's an interplay between hsp90
accessory proteins turned pro chaperones
and post-translational changes all of
which work together to allow normal
function of the chaperone machinery this
requires ATP binding and the resultant
conformational changes that are set in
motion and hsp90 inhibitors by
displacing ATP chrome hsp90 prevent
these conformational changes collapse
the chaperone machinery and prevent
hsp90 from chaperoning its clients war
so in cancer cells than in normal cells
and with that I would like to
acknowledge the folks in my lab over the
years that have performed all of the
experiments that I've shown you in this
talk and I also would like to
acknowledge our collaborators from the
medical oncology branch and laboratory
molecular pharmacology at NCI and also
our collaborators at the University of
Sussex in the United Kingdom with that I
would like to thank you for your
attention I hope you enjoyed the
presentation and found it informative
and we just like to add that you should
go to this website bio conference live
com / cme to obtain credits for
continuing education so that's it thanks
for your attention
and goodbye